so the department of justice launched
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
criminal investigations after january 6
was the largest dragnet in their history
they say
but somehow they did not arrest someone
caught on tape threatening to murder a
republican member of congress this is an
amazing story and there has been a big
development on this front
fox's kevin cork has it for us tonight
kevin incredible story indeed tucker
especially given what happened to
congressman steve scalise threats of
this nature get very intense scrutiny
here in the nation's capital as well
they should and in this case authorities
have acted albeit belatedly arresting
eugene hillsman last week in the la area
that arrest comes actually months after
an indictment was returned in may by a
federal grand jury prosecutors say that
back on january the 9th heusman
allegedly called the office of florida
congressman matt gates and threatened
him and his family
tell matt case to watch his back tell
him to watch his children tell him to
watch everyone i'm coming for him he's
gonna die he's a despicable
tyrant and i'm gonna kill him watch your
back i'm coming for you i'm gonna put a
bullet in you i'm gonna pull them bullet
in one of your kids too i hate you
incredible that happened back in january
and yet we're now hearing about an
arrest now by the way you may recall it
was about a week ago that congressman
gates gave a floor speech saying that a
man was traveling to d.c and threatening
to kill him
and despite the capitol police's
recommendation according to gates the
doj still didn't press charges by the
way houlsman is a longtime member of the
media having worked as a camera operator
for abc nbc
and cnn tucker
oh member of congress threatened with
death along with his children by a
former cnn employee told you why kevin
cork i appreciate you coming on tonight
anytime
thanks
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else